what's up everybody my name is Alan
dragu and we are back with another one
in fact today I'm going to give you 10
nasty lies that you've been told about
email marketing I'm going to distill
every single one of them to make sure
that you haven't been swindled in the
way that you build your personal brand
and serve your clients so let's Jump
Right In actually real quick before we
jump in please like And subscribe to
this video and to this channel so that I
know you appreciate this content it's
helpful to you and that you want more of
it otherwise I'm just going to be so sad
and I'm not going to make any more
videos and it's going to be a bad time
so don't do that to me come on subscribe
before you head out all right now let's
jump in lie number one and this is the
biggest lie of them all and the one I
hear the most often lie number one you
need to give value value is the number
one way that you email Market no it's
not all right value is not the number
one way that you email Market because we
live in an age where information is
everywhere and all this value and list
Les and here's things that you don't
know about this instead of focusing on
giving value focus on entertaining
somebody telling amazing riveting
stories okay making people laugh making
people feel something emotionally and
that is what makes them get attached to
you not only that but it makes them buy
too because you're doing something for
them that's more than just 10 things you
should read they don't want any more
that crap you are an Entertainer not an
information Giver so don't give value
entertain line number two beautiful
emails are better than plain text lie
complete lie you know why because
beautiful emails feel like Mass
marketing there's this old Gary Halpert
lesson where he talks about the a stack
and the B stack when somebody gets home
and they open their mailbox and they
take the mail what they do is they
separate their mail into two sacks one
sack is the burn pile that look looks
and feels and tastes and smells like ads
credit cards buy my this buy my that and
it feels garbagey and then there's the B
pile which could be personal letters to
you you don't want to throw it away if
you got a letter from your grandma if
you got a letter from your parents a
letter from a friend whatever it is
something important to you and that
looks like mail just normal mail your
email is the same if I open your emails
and it looks like a mass advertisement
you're going in my a burn pile you're
gone you're out of here I don't want to
read it but if I open an email and it's
just plain text how my grandma would
email me or how I would email my grandma
hey Grandma wanted to let you know about
this blah blah blah here's this crazy
story of me and Frank we were doing this
and it's a one-on-one email I'm more
likely to build a relationship with you
and feel like you wrote it for me so no
beautiful emails are not the way to go
ugly plain text emails get you into the
stack you want to be and that's not the
burn pile stack line number three once a
week is the perfect ratio to send your
email false what if I talk to my wife
once a week would we still have a good
relationship probably not no we can't do
that in fact if you want to build a
relationship with your people which is
99% of building a personal brand once a
week is not enough I email once a day
how am I supposed to email once a day
they're going to unsubscribe and they're
going to leave good we'll talk about
that in a little bit but you want to
build a relationship so they need to
hear from you they need to hear your
stories they need to understand why
you're talking to them and how you can
help them and what happens is you become
the authority the teacher the friend who
shows up every single day and is guiding
them along their journey of whatever
they're doing I'm helping copywriters
you might be helping Runners you might
be helping doctors you might be helping
Financial people whoever you're helping
you're guiding them along the journey
once a day because once a week honestly
isn't enough to build a relationship and
it hurts your sales imagine creating an
offer once a week Imagine creating an
offer once a day which clearly leads me
to line number four unsubscribes are
terrible no they're not unsubscribes are
natural list cleansers okay this is the
way that you get the people who aren't
serious about your journey off your list
you don't want luk warm people on your
list and in fact there's a lesson in the
Bible in Revelation when Jesus is
talking to the seven churches he's
talking to a couple of them and he's
reprimanding them and he's saying a
couple of them you are lukewarm and I
spit you out because you need to either
be hot or cold either you're Allin or
you're out lukewarm out that's your
unsubscribes when people unsubscribe
they're saying I'm lukewarm or I'm cold
I'm not hot for your stuff I don't care
about what you're doing as much as you
do and I'm not really on the journey
that you're on good leave get out of
here you don't want those people
cluttering your list cuz you're not
looking for followers you're looking for
fans so unsubscribes is a natural list
cleanser lie number five long emails
don't convert to sales false boring
emails don't convert to sales long
emails and long copy has been around
since the beginning of this whole schema
of copyrighting okay boring is the death
of writing but when you write long form
copy about something that's riveting and
interesting to your reader they'll read
eight pages 10 pages 20 Pages 30 pages
in fact legendary Gary Ben saanga the
highest paid living copy writer right
now his average sales letter is eight
pages average that means he has some one
of his bestselling sales letters is 23
Pages oh nobody's going to read all that
yes they are because they're interested
in the problem you solve because you
made it about the reader and not about
yourself so long copy has nothing to do
with lack of sales boring unrelatable
copy does line number six open rates are
King false you cannot cash open rates at
the bank okay open rates are vanity
metrics yes open rates do help make sure
that people open your email and they
read your email and they get to the
bottom but I know a lot of people who
have lower open rates and a lot more
sales because they have fans and
followers who are truly dedicated and so
open rates is a vanity metric not to
mention they're falsely measured on
these platforms okay every email
platform I've been on cannot properly
measure open rates because Android has
blockers and and Apple has blockers and
so you can't even measure what you can
measure is sales and sales buys food
food feed your family sales is the only
metric you should measure as a
copywriter okay doesn't matter if they
readd it did they buy from it sales is
King lie number seven emails should
nurture before they sell why does
somebody not have the problem do they
not have the problem today imagine if I
were to go to a suit manufacturer like a
Men's Warehouse or something and I would
go walk in and say sir I need a suit I'm
going to a wedding this week and I would
like a suit and they'd say Sir for
before you buy anything hold on sit down
sit down we'd like to get you a nice
whiskey we'd like to get you some food
we'd like to take you to a tour around
the suits we're not really selling we're
nurturing you today we want you you to
feel good and comfortable before you buy
and I say I'm comfortable I need a suit
I need a suit today I don't understand
why can't I buy a suit they say Sir
relax I know you have a problem I know
that you need a suit I know we could
solve that problem but I'm not selling
anything today I'm nurturing today do
you realize how crazy that sounds if
you're selling something valuable and
the person who just got on your list has
that problem they should get the
opportunity to purchase from you every
single day because today they might
decide to solve that problem and so
you're not selling Hard Sell buy my
stuff you're giving them an opportunity
to say yes to the thing that you are
offering and if they don't take that
opportunity that's fine you'll talk to
them tomorrow or you'll help them the
next day or whatever but you present
that opportunity every day you don't do
this nurture thing yes build
relationships love on your people help
them entertain them give them value all
of those things but don't not give them
the opportunity to buy and solve their
problem line number eight okay you need
to have a huge list to make any money
false in fact there's a great story from
Daniel throssel if you're not on his
email that's he's fantastic where he
only had 1,000 people on his list when
he did a launch that netted
$28,000 1,000 people generated $28,000
on his first launch why because he had a
quality list he had a list of people who
were highly interested in his product
which is exactly what I was talking
about when I did a video on getting a
quality list over a quantity list having
a big 10,000 person list of random
people pitch patch from random platforms
and random verticals random niches who
are not really interested you get this
broad audience of people well that's not
as good as a great tiny list okay a
1,000 person list generating 20 $ 28,000
in revenue is only possible because of
quality not quantity lie number number
nine email marketing is a dying industry
false social media engagement rates are
anywhere between 3 to 10% 10% being on
the very high range an average healthy
email relationship is anywhere between
30 to 60% that's 10 times the amount of
Engagement that you would get on a
social media platform here's an example
if you have 10,000 followers on Twitter
and you have a 3% engagement rate that
is 300 people who saw your Tweet
commented responded whatever 300 people
on 10,000 okay if you have a 1,000
person email list and you have a 30%
open rate that's also 300 people who saw
an interacted with your list okay do you
understand the difference I have to have
10,000 followers on the social media
platform to get the same amount of
Engagement as having 1,000 email
subscribers on my email list it's not
even in the same ballpark not to mention
social media is owned by Zuck and Elon
and those guys so they could change the
algorithm at the cough or whatever they
feel like they just change it and so
you're screwed because whatever you were
getting yesterday you're not going to
get tomorrow unless you're paying for
ads now so with the email list you own
people's information to be able to
contact them directly and you have the
opportunity to build relationships with
them so you serve your list well you
love them well and yes it absolutely
crushes social media algorithms which
leads me to line number 10 chat GPT is
the most efficient way to do email
marketing no chat gbt is a fake robot
that can be helpful in other aspects
automating some of the mundane work that
you do doing some research for you
things like that but it is not an email
writer for you because your job in
emails what relationships how can chat
gbt build what it doesn't makees it
doesn't work doesn't work because cha PT
is not a human and it doesn't know your
people and it's not talking back and
forth to your people and so efficiency
is a terrible way to have a long-term
mindset into building a brain Chachi PT
is not the way yes it could do some
things but your job is to be a human and
talk to your people write build
relationships and offer them products
that solves their problems through those
relationships all right that wraps us up
10 lives guys that you have been told
about email marketing I've distilled
them for you I've crushed them and
shoved them into the ground and I hope
you never listen to them ever again so
that was enjoyable to you make sure to
like And subscribe before you head out
lastly in the description I have a gift
for you if you are a copywriter you want
to make sure that you grab copyrighting
Catalyst 63 cash cow copyrighting tips
that you can get today instantly in your
email box and start reading each tip
will take you 90 seconds or less to read
you can apply it today and start making
money so hope that helps and I will
catch you on the next one people be
lying for no reason I'm tired of people
lied I don't want to lie that's a sin
you know what I'm saying it's a bad Sin
Jesus don't like liars M Jesus is not
about them liars and I ain't sitting on
Judgment Day about to tell Jesus I'd be
lying to all these email marketers mm no